I thought I knew everything about you
great musician you're terrific comic
actor you do it all I didn't know that
you were a coin collector I am and we
call it new myths mattes in the industry
in the coin collector we're out of time
[Applause]
yes yes check it out look it up its new
myths minutest but you're serious about
it you're a serious coin collector I
love my coins I have my favorites um one
of them that's really precious to me is
the flowing hair penny it's this
gorgeous in like 1793 and it's just this
beautiful bust of a woman and her hair
is flowing in the breeze and at the time
people were shocked when they saw it
because we have a kind of a puritanical
society that that's pornographic you
can't show a woman with a hair in the
breeze and they stopped making that corn
and now if you can find that coin they
didn't make very many of them it's worth
like your car yeah yeah you we have a
picture yeah so that freaks people out
just gorgeous it's gorgeous yeah it
looks like Roger Daltrey of the who and
it's and it's kind of representative of
the woman that we hold to put her in the
puritanical yeah and then I got another
corn that's it that's a similar theme
the Standing Liberty quarter in 1916 she
had an exposed breast and you can tell
how good a quality is I'm not joking by
the nipple if the nipple is erect you
know that is like good quality and can
we show a pic let me see you have one
this is a real thing I'm not kidding
and that in like 1970 and like at the
end of 1917 1918 they they said no she's
pornographic put this chainmail that
gave her a chainmail shirt to cover the
breast and then this is my spiciest coin
this is a real rare watch this was a
real rare one wasn't it called in 1828
they put out this Lincoln it's a
standing Lincoln
I believe it's Ken can we sit and we put
I had to pixelate the Johnson because
it's a full monty yeah and that's worth
wait so he's not wearing pants no and
they only made one of this coin
yeah and it's literally worth my house
yeah Wow and that came out in 1828 yeah
when Lincoln won when Lincoln was 19
years old and not famous
can we see the coin again yeah it says
19th yeah that one's a fake I don't know
where you got I think we have our fake
here I think our fake as well together
G Lincoln's Johnson indeed yeah I didn't
sell it right but I'm telling you the
Lincoln's Johnson Full Monty coin show
[Laughter]
you